hi everyone my name is nathra srinivasan
and my research project is the effect of
the onset of menopause on the
transcriptomic profile of the aging
female brain
there appears to be a divergence in the
occurrence of neurodegenerative diseases
between
males and females but the mechanisms so
far are unknown
for example for alzheimer's disease more
than 5.5 million americans are living
with alzheimer's disease
of whom two-thirds are elderly females
in addition the mitochondria of younger
females are protected against
the pathologies of alzheimer's disease
such as beta-amyloid toxicity reactive
oxygen species and apoptogenic signals
compared to their male counterparts
however this advantage
is lost in the mitochondria of elderly
females
and the difference between the younger
females and the elderly females
is this transition into menopause
and in addition current alzheimer's
treatments only target acetylcholine and
glutamate
um neurotransmitters in order to treat
the symptoms
but they are not treating the root cause
and so because of this discrepancy
between the two genders
and this transitioning into menopause
it's important
to figure out the underlying causes to
be able to better target treatments
so i will be um figuring out what is
going on as a female ages and if there
are any transcriptomic differences to
identify the genes at play
as well as pinpoint pathways to better
target treatments
first of all to give some background
information about female aging menopause
is the end of a female's menstrual cycle
and fertility
in which the ovaries no longer produce
estrogen and progesterone
in this project i will be looking at
data obtained from
rats and rat menopause so the ages that
i will be talking
about here are in rats age
so the first stage is pre-menopause
which is about six months for
rats and this is when they have normal
menstrual cycles
then they have transition into
perimenopause at around nine months
in which the cycles are irregular but
they have not stopped completely
then they transition into menopause at
about nine months
which starts with the final menstrual
cycle
and then at around 15 months they will
be at in post menopause which
in humans this is the year mark
from the final cycle now
to continue on about a little bit of
background about the aging of the female
brain
as the brain ages it's shown that there
is an increased immune response
and this is obtained from mishra el from
which
uh i am using the data from
so for the data set distribution um i'm
using transcriptomic data
from the rat female hippocampus
and there are six groups with six
samples each so there is the
female rat at six months or reg six
m and then at nine months normal
menstrual cycle or reg nine
m then nine months irregular menstrual
cycle which is erect nine m
uh nine months acyclic menstrual cycle
acyclic
9m then ovx at nine months which is
overrectimized and overrectimize
basically models the most
important clinical features of estrogen
deficiency induced or
post-menopausal conditions and this way
it acts as a control for my
experiment and then there's also uh the
female rat
at 16 months acyclic menstrual cycle or
acyclic
16m so my research
question and hype for my research
question and hypothesis
i'd like to understand the genes
expressed um differently in the
progressive stages of female
aging and menopause which can help us
understand the risks for
neurodegeneration and pathways to target
in order to treat near degeneration such
as
for alzheimer's disease in women so
the different ideas that i'm looking at
as how is the age and time of the onset
of menopause affecting the transcriptome
expression and which pathways are
affected and are the bar
are there biomarkers and menopausal
women that can help us identify their
risk for certain neurodegenerative
disorders or how does the expression
differ in overectomized
specimens and regular specimens and can
this lead to insights on the onset of
neurodegenerative disease
and my central question is what are the
effects of the onset of menopause on the
transcriptomic profile of the aging
female brain
so i hypothesize that as the females
enter premenopause and peri-menopause
they'll
express less genes related to
neurodegeneration as
the females and menopause and
post-menopause
and basically uh that the age and the
age of the onset do have an effect
on the transcriptomics of the rat
so for my methodology um since there are
six groups to compare i'll be using
principal component analysis
um dc2 which is differential gene
expression analysis and hierarchical
clustering
in order to relate the expression to
each other and draw conclusions
analyze what genes are overexpressed and
underexpressed and the six groups and
look at the significantly expressed
genes to annotate their function and
david and richard to see the pathways
that are expressed
so firstly here um with my preliminary
pca i found that there appeared to be
a divergence between the regular
groups and the irregular and acyclic
groups
and therefore i uh grouped it into
regular versus acyclic and regular
versus irregular
and as we can see in the pca they're two
different clusters for regular versus
irregular
um which shows that they're different
and for the regular versus
irregular um there does not appear to be
two
separate clusters but that's only
because um the components
are very small but once i um did
differential expression and i
did the pca again for the um separate
uh significant genes i found that there
appeared to be
two distinct clusters and also to test
the control
um i did pca between the regular versus
ovx and i found that there were two
different clusters
showing that there appears to be a
divergence when there's the shift into
menopause
and it cancels out for the age
and uh continuing on from my
differential expression
um i obtained some plots such as these
volcano plots which shows the
significant
genes um and i also found that
the pathways that are upregulated in
both the regular versus irregular and
regular versus acyclic were um functions
related to
the immune system and the pathways that
were down regulated were related to
mitochondrial dysfunctioning um such as
oxidative phosphorylation and the
mitochondrial respiratory chain complex
which in turn leads to the down
regulation of the pathways for
neurodegeneration such as
alzheimer's parkinson's and huntington's
and for further hierarchical clustering
i found that there appeared to be two
different clusters
um which shows that there is a
discrepancy between the regular versus
acyclic and the regular versus irregular
and i did pathway analysis with the
functional annotation
and i have images over here um
showing the relative expression of the
upregulated and down regulated pathways
so here's
upregulated immune system um
downregulated related to the
mitochondrial function
and near degenerative diseases same
thing over here for regular versus
acyclic and so for my conclusion
and discussion i found that there is an
impact on the transcriptomics of the rat
especially in relation to the
mitochondrial function leading to
neurodegenerative diseases such as
alzheimer's and parkinson's and
huntington's
i also found that the immune system is
heightened
um through this data and this helps me
say that um the pathways that should be
targeted for possible treatments of near
degenerative diseases
should be um in relation to oxidative
stress
um and this also supports the current
pathologies for alzheimer's in which
um the accumulation of the beta amyloid
um plaques exacerbates the oxidative
stress which damages the mitochondrial
structure
which shows that through targeting
menopause we can possibly be able to
find
certain treatments because menopause
appears to be a factor
in the onset of near-degenerative
diseases now for my limitations i was
not able to extract this data myself in
a lab and i had to use the data that
other researchers extracted from their
samples
so i was not able to control the sample
size or the procedures used to collect
the data and therefore i'm dependent on
the collection strategy
to obtain my results and
uh for the implications um by
now that we uh through my project we can
see that menopause is a factor on
the oxidative stress which leads to
these neurodegenerative diseases
um by being able to remove the oxidative
the cause of the oxidative stress um
according to coal
at all um with the oxidative stress
it creates damage on the mitochondria
but once the cause of the oxidative
stress
is removed the mitochondrial membrane is
actually able to
rebound and maintain
its structure again which could possibly
help us
with um targeting for neurodegenerative
diseases
and could be revolutionary to the field
so thank you for listening to my
presentation